Spain has BOX now, yes,
but BOX had Spain long before even it existed.
BOX had judges also in the Constitutional Court
long before it had any elected representative.
BOX controls the police, the military and the judiciary.
The king of Spain was appointed by his corrupt,
fugitive father, who in turn got in the crown from Franco.
Spain chain of legitimacy dates back to 1939.
Fascist victory.
The only extreme right victory in Europe that never got overturned.
When it comes to Catalonia,
all Spanish authorities subscribe to the agenda of the extreme right.
And as long as Russia protects them,
you are complicit in advancing the political testament
dictated by Franco in his death bed. Thank you very much.